[Applause]
then store are at four present era Nobel
Prize Turin in literature it is a great
honor to introduce the Nobel laureate in
literature mr. Kazu issue guru
[Applause]
your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
excellencies fellow laureates ladies and
gentlemen I remember the large face of a
foreigner a western man illustrated in
rich colors dominating the whole page of
my book behind his looming face to one
side was smoke and dust from an
explosion on the other side
rising from the explosion white birds
climbing to the sky I was five years old
lying on my front on a traditional
Japanese tatami mat perhaps this moment
left an impression because my mother's
voice somewhere behind me was filled
with a special emotion as she told the
story of a man who had invented dynamite
then concerned about his applications
had created the Nobel Shah I first heard
of it but despised Japanese name the
Nobel Shah she said was to promote heiwa
meaning peace or harmony this was just
14 years after our city nagasaki had
been devastated by the atomic bomb and
young as I was I knew heiwa was
something important that without it
fearful things might invade my world the
Nobel Prize like many great ideas is a
simple one something a child can grasp
and that is perhaps why it continues to
have such a powerful hold on the world's
imagination the pride we feel when
someone from our nation wins a Nobel
Prize it's different from the one we
feel witnessing one of our athletes
winning an Olympic medal we don't feel
the pride of our tribe demonstrating
superiority over other tribes
rather it's the pride that comes from
knowing that one of us has made a
significant contribution to our common
human endeavor the emotion aroused is a
larger one a unifying one we live today
in a time of growing tribal enmities of
communities fracturing into bitterly
opposed groups like literature my own
field the Nobel Prize is an idea that in
times like these helps us to think
beyond our dividing walls that reminds
us of what we must struggle for together
as human beings it's the sort of idea
mothers will tell their small children
as they always have all around the world
to inspire them and to give themselves
hope am i happy to receive this honor
yes I am I am happy to receive the Nobel
Shore as I instinctively called it when
minutes after receiving my astounding
news I telephoned my mother now 91 years
old I more or less grasped its meaning
back then in Nagasaki and I believe I do
so now I stand here old
that I've been allowed to become part of
its story thank you
[Applause]